foreign
good evening members uh good evening
members of the public good evening
everybody and welcome to the uh this
District area planning committee held on
Thursday the 1st of December 2022. my
name is councilor Kevin Lagan and I'm
the chairman of this committee I'm
joined this evening by officers in
person Mr Matt Lee Lee specialist placed
um Miss Anna testoster specialist
development manager who's a case officer
and remotely by Tara Berg committee
Clerk and Ben Harrison who's responsible
for streaming
members were streaming this meeting live
and as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you're given your
consent to being recorded during each
item please put your hand up to indicate
if you wish to speak I will then invite
you at the appropriate time please note
that the YouTube live stream sound
recording is dependent on the correct
use of microphones therefore can I ask
you when invited to speak and remember
to turn your microphone turn it off when
you've finished
please keep a reference to a page or
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda paper and please keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible
Tara any apologies for absence please
thank you chairman that's great thanks
Tara
um we move on to the minutes of the
previous meeting uh
apologies thank you chairman I can't
remember was Council
has she asked me to send her apologies
this morning when I saw as a councilor
holds not attending a guitar did you get
that Council holds not attendance
is supposed to know you can add that to
the list thank you that's brilliant
thanks councilor Sam members will move
on to the minutes it's recommended the
minutes of the meeting held on the 27th
of October found on pages 7 to 18 are
approved as a true and accurate record
I so moved do I have a second for that
motion a councilor none thank you
any member wish to speak on any matters
of accuracy on the minutes
excellent okay we'll move on to section
four Declarations of interest to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecune to your interests are
the registerable interests and
non-registerable interests relating to
the items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraph 9 and
appendix B of the code of conduct for
members members are reminded that they
are also required to disclose any such
interests as soon as they become aware
should the knees arise throughout the
meeting members do I have any
Declarations of Interest
perfect thank you very long we'll move
along to agenda item five uh which is
found on pages 19 to 80. this is item
five the application number is
22.00523 resm land at Broad Street Green
Road Maple Road and langfield Langford
Road in haybridge and also draw members
attention to the members update that's
been distributed today we do have one
public speaker but we'll go to the
public speaker after Miss testoster
group has presented the report Anna
could you be kind enough to do that
thank you thank you chairman thank you
so
um I just noted that since the
publication of the members update a
consultation response from Sports
England has been received raising no
comments uh in relation to the
application
uh so the application is presented to
tonight's for me to following deferral
from the last District planning
committee on the 27th of October and the
application was deferred by Committee in
order for the applicant to consider
revising the scale height and design of
the North Eastern block of flats
proposed within parcel 12. Amendments
have been included and they will they
are included into this presentation
as you already know
uh this application relates to the
largest of the three sites allocated
within the North hayward's Garden suburb
The Proposal relates to phase two of the
approved development any particular the
land that is reserved for the delivery
of the residential paracels at 10 11 and
12.
um
following the Pharaoh The Proposal would
still seek planning permission for the
construction of
262 residential units with Associated
access parking servicing and Landscaping
the main revisions Incorporated to the
scheme include the replacement of the
previously proposed block of floods
three-story block of Flats on the corner
here to the north east of parcel 12 with
two smaller in size and two-story in
height
blocks of flats as you can see on that
plan
uh the number of units typed and you the
right all of it Remains the the same
this is the master plan and I'm going to
go through all of the previous plans
quickly just because they've been
revised but nothing significant other
stains has changed apart from this uh
part of parcel 12.
um so the proposal would still include
79 affordable units I would still comply
with the density parameter plan and the
building Heights parameter plan this is
in the illustrative landscape plan
uh Garden sizes would still need the
Moreland District design guide standards
materials are the same as before
parking one parking space the only thing
that's the only difference that one
parking space will be provided for its
uh flat one and two bedroom Flats
this is the permeability plan the refuse
collection
um sorry whoops uh car starting all of
the units will be provided with a
minimum one uh EV targeting point
the boundary treatment
this relates to the different type of
houses along the northern boundary of
the side to be more traditional because
they are closer to the listed buildings
24 different types of houses are
proposed and four different types of
apartment blocks
instead of three these are some streets
and elevations this one has been changed
here you can see the proposed block of
flats this is the view from Broad Street
Green Road foreign
elevations that have not been affected
by the revisions
some more
uh here I have included the previously
proposed and the currently proposed
scheme so this is what was previously
proposed uh the three-story block of
lads and now these has been split into
two smaller two-story blocks of flats as
you can see on that streets in elevation
um some water suits and elevations
these are the plans and elevations of
the other blocks of floods on the other
side of parcel 12 these are the same
they have not been amended
uh apart from Blog the same on the
western part of parcel 12 has not been
amended from the previous proposal these
are the amended
apartment blogs so this is uh one of the
two
their elevations and plants and
elevations
of the other block Flats these are the
revised as I said
um a selection of the houses that they
are proposed that they were included in
the previous presentation they have not
been amended as I said no new or
different types of houses are proposed
some two bedroom dwellings
and some three bedroom dwellings
and four bedroom dwellings
these are the carriages and here are
some visuals
this is View from hybrids wood
this is the view of the this is the view
of the apartment blog as previously
proposed and
[Music]
honestly I don't know what is
good
sorry and this is the I don't know
what's going on with my phone so I've
left it in there anyway so this is the
this is the uh this is the Vlog uh this
is the block of flat as previously
proposed and this is how it has been
amended as you can see it's been
replaced with two blocks of two sorry
blocks of flats one is this one and one
is this one
and some visuals from the northern part
of the side
this is from the spine roads towards the
North
these are some visuals of the other
blocks of floods on the other side of
parcel 12.
and some photographs of the site it's
your all where I were
um so hybrids Road and the application
side
and this is views of the application
side and here are some views on the
opposite side of Broad Street Green Road
um so the principle of development is
previously discussed uh is considered
acceptable the details of the
residential element of these phase two
of the development are considered to
Accord with the North haybridge Garden
strategic master plan framework and the
North Haven strategic design code the
approved parameter plans and the outline
planning permission to which it relates
overall it is considered there is the
revised layout Mass height form design
appearance and Landscaping of the
development would be acceptable and it
would Accord with a it would be a good
representation of the character areas
that are aimed for this section of the
North havers Garden suburb it is also
considered the scheme as revised would
overcome the concerns raised previously
by members in relation to the scale mass
and height of the previously proposed
apartment block on these basis the
scheme is proposed for uh approval
subjects to conditions on pages 25 to 30
of the agenda those revised within the
members update and also subject to the
revision of the plans
the plan numbers included in condition 7
to reflect to reflect the latest
revisions
we do have one person to speak Mr Jane
McArthur if you'd like to come forward
please Jamie
foreign
you have two minutes from the time you
start talking
um to Lodge your information thank you
thank you good evening members um hello
again my name is Jamie mccove from
belway homes
um thank you for the opportunity to
address the committee again tonight as
there no objectives I will keep this
brief and I will focus on the reason for
deferral from the last committee
um we have listened to your comments
um at the last committee and revised our
proposals accordingly haven't seen now
the officer's presentation of the
revised scheme it's clear the scheme has
been significantly approved and the
reduction of high on the corner of Broad
Street Green ensures that the characters
retained with more traditional two-story
homes
um these homes are in excess of sort of
80 meters away from existing properties
uh should we receive approval tonight
we'll be on site in Spring 23 and
completed
um on-site by 2526 which is
approximately 87 units per year
uh there is a section 106 League already
in place which ensures the delivery of
affordable homes and wider
infrastructure including the Open Spaces
and play facilities
Etc in summary the principal development
has been established by the outline
planned permission and this application
is fully compliant with the requirements
of that permission and we have revised
application to take into account your
comments from the last meeting as such
the officers I've concluded that
proposals are acceptable and planning
terms and I asked members to approve the
application in accordance with the
officer's recommendations
um thank you again for your time and
your comments and very much look forward
to any questions
thank you thank you Mr McArthur
if you 'd just like to go thank you
better get Council if we go back in
okay any other comments Mr Lee no okay
um members we we have recommendations
which are found on page 19 the reports
would prove subject conditions in
Section 8 and on pages four to six of
the members update
um Second and thank you so that's
proposed by councilor Durham second
about Council white members open the
chamber for debate
I can't cancel
Edmonds
okay thank you anybody hands you
okay could I start with cancer settle
please thank you uh thank you chairman
uh yeah I think what has come back from
the developer is now very much in
keeping with the character of the road
and it fits with what the b1022 is which
is a rural road and it's a rural road
all the way from Malden to Colchester
and we have kept that character with
this new development and in terms of the
scale of these apartments and I think
it's now a great design and it will not
be something that is an imposition on on
that Rural Road
thank you cancel the schedule
uh Council redwoods
uh thank you chairman um
first of all I'd like to thank the
Developers for actually coming back with
revised plan and quite quickly too so
that's appreciated but I would like to
just point out
something uh not actually on the plan
itself but the principle of garden
suburbs
um
the principal of garden suburbs is
integrating new development
and existing communities for their
Mutual benefit and I would like to refer
members to our local development plan
page 35 paragraph 2.73
and I'll read I quoted it is essential
that cycling and walking networks
influence the structure of new
development
strategic cycle routes will be developed
to establish safe local connections
between new and existing neighborhoods
walking routes will be established based
on the existing public footpath network
and new links will provide direct access
to local destinations and will link
existing and new neighborhoods
now I wanted to just to point this out
to members that
due to recent
issues not related to this
um to this application it has proven
that this has not been taken to account
in previously
um so I just wanted to bring this to
your attention
that it's essential that connectivity
between the garden suburbs and the
existing communities is
made available to the public so thank
you very much thank you councilors
Council Spencer please
what we're dealing with here is the
reserved matters
um as
the officer has said
um this is in accordance with the
already approved parameter plan however
I'm glad that we hung out last time that
we went back to the developer and asked
for something different for those
residents because
um I think that's the least that we
could do given all the circumstances so
I'm really grateful that that's come
back altered I want to very quickly back
up everything that councilor Edwards has
just said because we deal with this on a
daily basis we have small children
walking down Broad Street Green Road we
nearly lost a four-year-old autistic boy
a couple of weeks ago because he ran
because he was so scared by the fast
lorries passing him at 40 miles an hour
and it was their only way of getting to
primary school at that time due to an
ongoing issue that we can't mention here
as we've said
um so I'd love to see some safety
improvements for Broad Street Green Road
but I I have to say that were this not
already approved in outline I would
wouldn't be supporting a site with a
road like that now and I have to say
that I wonder what went on in the past
and I never quite understand it but I do
thank the developer for coming back with
what he has today thank you thank you
councilor Spencer as a whole
get powerful people sorry
it's been a long day and
that's being all serious come on
right thank you I'd like to start off by
thanking the Developers for taking on
board what my account what myself and
councilor siddle highlighted I mean what
they actually proposed was very similar
to the development where he had up by
Malden from Town Football Club Great Big
Lots of flats right on the entrance I
don't understand the logic in that but
I'm not a developer
um
the other plus points to me is the fact
we've got electricity points from I
think all the houses from what I could
see from them minuscule drawings which
are obviously taken by NASA
um what I am disappointed about is the
fact we haven't really considered any
solar panels or any heat pumps in as
we're not allowed any gas boilers after
2025. that to me would have been a
win-win for the people buying these
houses because now if you've got gas
boilers in there you're going to have to
Fork out
to get one but next time it's out
and
I'm sorry to say that is not a garden
suburb it's a housing estate
and the other thing I'd like to say is
if you can actually get the children out
of the bedrooms
I can't see any play areas for the
children I don't know what they're
supposed to do I mean I see once again
we've got the artistic
scope up there with the the views that
we're supposed to see
but I think you know there's good
artists for self
um
as I said not being a developer
personally I would have put anything
like a big bulk of flats and whatever
along a bypass which would be on the
left hand side which no one would have
taken any notice of
so to me it just seems ludicrous putting
it at the beginning of a development but
I mean it is what it is but as I said
I'm a bit disappointed it's not looking
more like a garden suburb as opposed to
a housing estate but
but I still like to thank them for
taking on board the items that we did
bring up
thank you councilor Beale uh any
comments
yeah thank you chairman
um only in relation to the uh plain
areas that you've said these are
included within the landscaping and
infrastructure strategic landscaping and
infrastructure so these are provided but
they are provided outside the
residential parcels and we are
considering those applications and the
count the committee has considered those
applications for for these phase phase
two in the past
thank you thank you very much
uh Council Swain
yes thank you Jim just a small um piece
for explanation the
um reduction in height and therefore
accommodation on this block on the that
has given the cause for concern has
meant
um slightly more intensification
somewhere else
in this passive land
um Are the officers satisfied that this
hasn't had a uh that the amount of
proper immunity space is still available
for these um there's this more intensive
area
um compliant as I said yes thank you
councilor fluka
yeah thank you Jim um can we just go
back and have a look at the visuals for
the proposed elevator the
the proposed change of design and the
previous design
so can you just okay so that's
what's coming now yeah that's what's
being proposed now and just flick back
to what's proposed before okay so go
back again
yeah I mean it might just be the way
it's been rendered but they still the
roofs still look very tall compared to
the the houses to the rear which look
like a pair of semi-detached houses
um you know that's just my observation
so I do hope that we don't have another
application come forward later to put
Dormer windows in the roof and I'm sure
that the the applicant would have heard
that and now can we just go to I think
you've got one with proposed landscape
foreign
so I I presume that this will be
conditioned so that this will be decided
by officers afterwards because I think
that it's very very important that when
we come to these meetings and we see
these landscape schemes and we see the
renderings and we see lots of trees and
everything else and then when these
developments are built out we don't see
so many trees and we don't see so many
you know Wonderful shrubs and everything
else and I think we can go to any new
development in the district and see that
and and I accept that once these schemes
have been agreed
um then the developers under an
obligation to replace any trees or
plants or shrubs that die but
unfortunately that clearly is not
happening in this District at the moment
and I know we've had one of the hottest
years and I just hope that when officers
consider landscape then
um I hope they bear in mind what's been
put before members today which I think
is acceptable but chairman this is you
know this is an absolute classic case
of the members Place shaping and and and
councilor siddles should be commended
because he specifically you know put
forward a reason to refuse this to bring
it back to do this this is what place
shaping is and and chairman I know you
you'll probably guess what I'm going to
say next but if only the policy team at
this Council had allowed the members to
play shape with the local development
plan we would be in a much better place
but chairman I think you've got a
proposal in the second in if I'm the
last to speak then I'd ask that you put
that to the council thank you committee
are any other members who'd like to
speak before we move forward
um I will make a comment um can we go
back to the visual where the the the
second flap
foreign
thank you and it's you probably know
what's coming from me to the Developers
my rule is as chair is to chair the
meeting but I will make a comment can we
please have a visual one day with all
the cars parked up after work and the
dust spins going around so we can see
what it really looks like yeah just this
yeah because that is Utopia but I'd like
to see Utopia that's just the view it's
not not you know anything more but I
would really love to see that one day
thank you members for indulging me okay
members we do have a a proposal and it's
been seconded
um so I'd like to put that to the vote
do members agree by a cent or do you
want to agreed anybody not agree because
it sounded like unanimous to me okay so
that's Carrie members thank you
um we move on to item six any other
urgent items of business that I decided
are Urgent there are none so members I'd
like to thank you for your contributions
this evening I draw the meeting to a
close at 6 7 55 p.m and wish you safe
travels thank you